[Music]
it's time for Koch news here we bring
you up to date on what's going on in
Hollywood and the rest of the movie and
series World we've got new information
about Deadpool 3 mission impossible 8
and the new Fallout series also Marvel's
W division spin-off is getting an update
and David Fincher talks about his World
War Z sequel get to learn that and much
more in this video enjoy Samaritan
Returns the superhero movie star
Sylvester Stallone seems to have
convinced enough people in 2022 that
Amazon has now confirmed work on
Samaritan 2 the first movie started out
as a so-called spec script this is a
script that an author writes with no
commission whatsoever and then tries to
pitch to Hollywood the Samaritan script
by BR FSH quickly made the rounds at the
time was eventually picked up by Amazon
and cast with Sylvester Stallone as an
aging superhero the story is about a boy
who is rescued by a sanitation worker he
slowly begins to suspect that the
unassuming man is the superhero
Samaritan who retired 20 years ago after
an epic battle with his arch enemies the
movie went straight to streaming and was
a huge hit according to Amazon it was
the most popular movie on the platform
for 3 weeks in a row of course the
streaming giant would like to replicate
such a success the script for Samaritan
2 is once again said to be by brj F shut
and Sylvester Stallone is also back on
board both as a producer and in the lead
role even though the star seems to have
withdrawn from his own action series The
Expendables 4 the movie Legend
apparently still wants to have a
blast the title of the new Ghostbuster
sequel has been revealed already 2
months ago a picture made the news in
which the well-known logo was completely
covered in ice now a leak apparently
reveals the official title many were
wondering what the Ghostbusters
afterlife sequel will be called the
answer now seems clear Ghostbusters the
new Ice Age at least that's the
translation of Dena iight in a German
social media note from Sony for the
Press surely an oversight presumably
this info shouldn't have seen the light
of day yet at least not before the
official announcement what exactly
Ghostbusters the new Ice Age will be
about is not yet known however the
post-credit scene of the predecessor
already hinted that they will probably
go back to New York to the legendary
headquarters the new film has so far
been appropriately given the working
title Firehouse named after the former
fire station Ghostbusters 2 the new Ice
Age is scheduled to hit the theaters on
March 29th
2024 finally the release date for
Amazon's highly anticipated Fallout
series is set the video game adaptation
awaits us on April 12th
2024 Fallout is a veritable classic in
video game history numerous games of the
post-apocalyptic role-playing series
have been released since 1997 and still
enjoy great popularity as early as July
2020 a series adaptation was announced
by Amazon via deadline and made fans
look forward to it with great
anticipation now it has finally been
revealed that the series will premiere
on Amazon Prime Video in early 2024 the
series will be produced by Christopher
Nolan's brother Jonathan Nolan and his
wife Lisa Joy who will also direct the
First episodes the cast includes Moises
Arius Johnny pton Aika Kendrick and the
hateful eight star Walton gogin The
Fallout video games tell of a
post-apocalyptic world destroyed by a
nuclear war in 20076
the players explore the radioactively
contaminated Earth and have to deal with
mutants scavengers and strange Cults for
example apart from a good sense of humor
the style of the American 1950s is a
particular characteristic of the series
according to initial information the
action will take place in
post-apocalyptic La we are eager to find
out whether the special feeling of the
games will carry over to the series we
can hardly
wait it's official at last Deadpool 3
can't meet need its release date in
early May in fact most people have
suspected this for a long time but now
Disney is adding Clarity instead Captain
America 4 might be able to come out on
its original release date the actor
strike is still keeping Hollywood under
control and a number of Studios have
already decided to give their movies new
release dates as a deadline now reported
Disney will postpone their hotly
anticipated sequel Deadpool 3
indefinitely although the corporation
usually sticks to its plan schedule for
a long time the movie production which
has been at a standstill for quite some
time is now likely to have finally led
to this decision currently there is
simply too much to do in terms of
reorienting the production therefore the
movie will take some more time to be
released nevertheless there is one piece
of positive news as initial sources have
already made known Captain America 4
Brave New World could get back its
original release date of May 3rd 2024
the production of the action film is
largely regarded as complete so the
chances are good that we can look
forward to Sam Wilson's new adventure
earlier than expected next
year World War Z2 directed by Master
director David Fincher we bet that's
music to your ears as part of the press
tour for his new movie The Killer on
Netflix Fincher now commented on the
sequel to The Zombie film The Action
horror starring Brad Pit grossed a
whopping $540 million in 2013 but was
hardly profitable due to the high costs
this made Fincher's plan sequel a risk
and led to the project being called off
for the time being Fincher had big plans
the goal was to create a similarly
multi-layered work like the last of us
and in fact according to the director
there would have been one or two
parallels ultimately he was glad that
nothing came of the sequel since the HBO
series offered more basis for dealing
with the topic but Fincher also hinted
that World War Z could still go ahead a
major point of criticism of part one was
that the action film had taken many
Liberties including a different ending
when asked if the intended SE sequel
would have been a more faithful
adaptation to the work the director said
no no but there is some talk of doing
that of course that sounds like one
thing above all a World War Z remake or
reboot a reboot that invests less money
in big action and focuses more on the
social and political consequences of the
zombie apocalypse maybe we can even
expect an exciting World War Z series in
the style of the last of us we are
curious to see whether the talks about a
new adaptation will bear fruit ideally
with David Fincher as producer and maybe
even as a director we'll keep you up to
date as
always Agatha Returns the W division
spin-off Agatha darkhold Diaries has
been on Marvel schedule for quite some
time now it has finally been announced
when the witch will be back and a
description of episode 1 was provided
along with it Agatha darkle Diaries will
kick off on September 19th 2024 with
actress Katherine Han who already played
an impressive part in the original
series slipping back into the role role
of the titular witch Disney now
published a new logo of the series with
the final title originally the series
was to be called Agatha House of
Harkness and later Agatha coven of chaos
it appears that a final new title has
now been agreed upon a first description
of episode 1 was also published making
you eager for more it says that in the
first episode we see Agatha Harkness
finally break out of a spell she has
been trapped in she can't wait to go
back to her old murderous ways only to
find that she is powerless
the only way forward for her is to
embark on a perilous quest to get her
powers back with the help of an unlikely
friend or two which friends are they
talking about well that's something we
can now speculate on Katherine Han is
joined by Aubrey Plaza as Rio Joe lock
as well as Patty Leone as Lilia Jack
Schaefer showrunner of w division will
be responsible for directing we are
already looking forward to the debut of
the series on September 19th 2024 and
are curious to see whether it can keep
up with W division
more movies are being postponed after
Disney has already rescheduled several
projects due to the actor strike
Paramount is now following suit as a
result there are new theatrical release
dates for the next 2 years in addition
to Deadpool 3 mission impossible 8 also
had to hold its production for an
indefinite period of time due to the
strike and has now been given a new
release date the new Mission featuring
Tom Cruz Simon Peg and Haley Atwell will
now no longer be released on June 28
2024 but most likely in summer of 2025
instead the horror prequel a quiet place
day 1 also faces a slight delay of about
3 months and will now be screened on
June 28th 2024 in the US next year's if
directed by John krinski and starring
Ryan Reynolds will be moved up a week to
May 17th 2024 it's about a man who can
see and talk to other people's Imaginary
Friends the new the SpongeBob movie
search for SquarePants will not be
released until the end of of 2025 on
December 19th to be
exact should you be interested in more
updates make sure to check out our
latest movie previews for inside out 2
and the Lord of the Rings The War of the
rerum we hope by watching these previews
you get even more excited for their
theatrical releases in 2024 if you like
this video give it a thumbs up and leave
a comment telling us what you thought of
this week's news thanks for
watching
[Music]